vorgestern hat sich in bayern zum ersten
mal der sogenannte runde tisch
artenvielfalt getroffen naturschützer
landwirte und bayerische regierung ein
ganz großer erfolg für das volksbegehren
rettet die bienen bei dem sich gerade
fast 1,8 millionen bajuwaren für mehr
artenschutz ausgesprochen haben und
siehe da plötzlich hat auch markus söder
ein herz für bienen beziehungsweise ohne
dem kopf er war ja klar das war ja
natürlich
ja der gelernte opportunist er spürt
wenn die stimmung kippt und setzt sich
flugs an die spitze der bewegung
das ist eine neue form einer
kooperativen demokratie eine form der
mitwirkung ist anliegen des
volksbegehrens ist auch unser anliegen
auch von mir ja da muss er selber lachen
was hat den super-g für artenschutz
getan oder oder gegen das schlimme
sitzen sterben in bayern nix nix der
minister so da stand immer für mehr
flächenversiegelung nicht für weniger
aber klar das war bevor 1,8 millionen
bayern abgestimmt haben er ist ja
flexibel sehr klar ja jetzt
jetzt hat er quasi sein alter öko
entdeckt könnte man sagen ja er sich so
schlimm verbiegen zu müssen da kann
einem doch fast leid tun oder
ich finde schon sagen wir mal der sänger
ist lernfähig und zeit wird unter
anderem wegen der ausgeprägten
monokultur in bayern für die ganze
biogasanlagen wird da unten ohne ende
mais und raps angebaut
und ja das mögen bieten gar nicht wobei
eigentlich geht es ja um wildbienen der
roten liste bedrohter tierarten nach
sind 40 wildbienenarten bereits
ausgestorben
ja dann hört doch auf die aufzuschließen
idioten
in deutschland gibt es heute 75 prozent
weniger fluginsekten als 1989 und 50
prozent weniger vögel
das sind erschreckende zahlen auch wenn
der lungenarzt köhler jetzt in einer
neuen studie sagte es gebe gar keine
sagte stern was mich aber auch ärgert
ist diese fixierung auf bienen nur weil
die so flauschig sind ich möchte hier
mal eine lanze brechen für weniger
attraktive insekten wie zb der eichen
zangen bock potthässlich aber bedroht
oder der der veilchen blaue wurzelhals
schnell käfer wird aber wichtig und
nicht zuletzt die braun fleckige
beißschrecke ja
wieso muss ich jetzt an wer trickst von
storch denken es ist egal
[Applaus]
schicke weiße
ja wenn die globale insekten masse
weiter jedes jahr um 25 prozent
schrumpft sind in 100 jahren alle
krabbeltiere verschwunden
rettet die bienen war das erfolgreichste
volksbegehren in der geschichte bayerns
und zwar trotz dieses songs
[Musik]
doch jetzt will ich schon weiß was uns
spaß
pro tag wird in bayern eine fläche von
zwölf hektar bebaut das sind 17
fußballfelder
diese fläche wird im wahrsten sinne des
wortes plattgewalzt der traktor hat dann
in run sonne weiß es wirklich so
ja
was schönes buch inzwischen das fakt
holen imker ihre völker schon in die
stadt weil die deiner stadt mehr nahrung
findet auf dem land das sind dann
offiziell stadt wien völlig neue gattung
also im grunde so hipster bienen die
fahren beim fixie weg zum yoga dann
lassen sie sich im barbershop den
vollbart und saugen am schluss bei
starbucks das kostenlose wlan weg
schiffskabinen ja was willst du machen
der bayer an sich betoniert halt gerne
und der großteil des flächenverbrauchs
geht bei denen für verkehr drauf also
für neue straßen und so was kein wunder
denn denn der freistaat profitiert
offenbar überproportional von
investitionsmitteln des
verkehrsministeriums liegt das etwa
daran dass der bundesverkehrsminister
selbst bayer ist das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen beim besten mit warum sollte
denn ein bayer den bayern mehr geld
geben ich leite die frage trotzdem auf
verdacht mal direkt weiter und sava
stockhaus er leitet im berliner
verkehrsministerium die abteilung für
verkehrswegeplanung und kackt reiste
spezlwirtschaft der stock aus die grünen
sagen ihr bayern kriegt schon seit
jahren mehr geld für straßen als alle
anderen bundesländer der welt im einsatz
beginnt mit die grünen sagen
und dann fährt sich ein teil meines
gehirns direkt runter notabschaltung
altes bayerisches sprichwort erst wenn
die letzte tankstelle geschlossen wurde
werdet ihr merken dass die grünen nachts
kein bier verkaufen
hersteller ist aber aber bayern hat in
den letzten zehn jahren nicht nur in
absoluten zahlen mehr geld für
bundesfernstraßen gekriegt sondern auch
die größte steigerung verbucht hat das
nicht doch was damit zu tun dass ihre
partei seit sekunde ich kommt nochmal
nach seit zehn jahren den
verkehrsminister stellt mein lieber herr
welke selbst trinke ich ihnen mal so gut
erhalten dass sie durch ihr nrw abitur
ein ein wenig das sagen wir mal
gehandicapt sind oder wie man heute sagt
herausgefordert selbst sie sollten
diesen verkehrsminister wirst du nicht
nach parteibuch verkehrsminister wird
immer der beste immer neuer dobrindt
ramsauer durch die bank titanen des
internets gefahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
welchen namen gibt herr absolut ein
beispiel nehmen sie noch mal den
ramsauer peter im prinzip fast rentner
aber wenn sie den im bundestag erleben
er hat immer noch dieser präsenz a
wahnsinn
das war übrigens kein foto schade und
solchen giganten zu unterstellen sie
hätten bayern bevorzugt da muss ich
wirklich sagen pfui deibel herr welke 3
x naja aber herr stocker aus es gibt
noch einfach zahlen über 2 milliarden
euro für den bundesfernstraßenbau sind
im letzten jahr aus berlin über den
weißwurstäquator geflossen wie in nrw
als einwohnerstärksten verkehrs
reichstes land haben 2018 nur knapp 1,4
milliarden bekommen ja gut erstens was
will nrw überhaupt mit straßen
ihr macht sie doch eben nur kaputt auf
der a3 da gibt es schlaglöcher der
verschwinden ganze rumänische schweina
das da auf nimmerwiedersehen
und zweitens wir bayern kriegen deswegen
mehr geld weil wir fleißiger bauanträge
stellen
durch unsere weit überlegen den schulen
haben wir nämlich beamte die rechnen
können also mit plus - und sogar ein
bruch wahnsinn geplant besser aber zu
weit gehört auch csu verkehrsminister
haben die voerder spielregeln geändert
immer mehr sogenannte sonderprogramme
und bei denen geht eben nicht der
normale verteilschlüssel zwischen den
ländern sondern das windhund prinzip wer
zuerst kommt kriegt die kohle
also bayern das ist doch faktor stock
aus ja aber man muss ja auch hätte wenn
sie das so sagen und dann würde ich
gerne ablenken mit einem bild von einer
sehr sehr niedlichen biene ja schauen
sie mal wie süß die in honig syrien ich
zum beispiel ich bin eine br
summ summ in einem unbekannten
geschlagen
guten tag ich könnte ich sie für ein abo
des heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab